good job guy Pierce you're probably
gonna give me nightmares now Wallace so
Louis is a story that takes place in
prohibition-era Virginia and of course
when something becomes illegal there's
now a black market for so people made
moonshine and they sold it moonshines
you know shitty alcohol let it gets the
job done now it's a party
so Shia LeBeouf Tom Hardy and family
they make moonshine and they sell it you
know crime and murder and money you know
the good stuff or so first of all let's
talk about Shia LaBeouf cuz he's really
the main character in this movie
Shia LaBeouf was really good in this
movie and I'm glad I'm glad we got to
see him in another role other than
explosions it's always good when an
actor can show their acting chops Shia
LaBeouf does have them it is his romance
with this one chick chick from Alice in
Wonderland specifically and you know
it's really cute thing going on you know
you're like all right cool
go for it man she killed the Jabberwocky
after all so I'm glad Shia LaBeouf
carried his weight in this movie a big
weight it was he's the main character
Tom Hardy I loved seeing Tom Hardy
dude's a great actor I just wish he said
more literally a lot of the times he was
like that was his line of dialogue I
loved his voice though it's pretty much
you know what happens to Bane when he
loses the fight for Gotham soul and then
he just goes into Prohibition era
America and gets trash Brown let's not
stand on ceremony here mr. Wayne he was
a man of few words but the dude took
action I loved how he never really
flipped his top he kept his cool all the
time and someone could get their head
ripped off right in front of him he'll
be like mm I like people like that as
long as they have the right cast
characters and actors around that person
who can counterbalance the fact that he
doesn't talk that much it works and it
did in this movie let's get down to
business here Guy Pearce is in this
movie he's the agent trying to shut down
all the moonshine he's like nope not
having it the fact is he's one creepy
son of a he has all the character
traits of the serial killer it turns out
though he works for the government he
has this creepy middle part yours like
Muir you're off dude again where's
Dexter when you need him this guy would
be like a perfect villain for Dexter
finally after the past two shitty
seasons they've had Gary Oldman's in the
movie kind of I won't like Gary Oldman
had one of the best introductions that a
character has had
in a movie all year one of anyway he
just gets out of his car takes it
Thompson and just shreds this car with
this guy in it takes a tommy gun to the
entire thing after that he's in like one
more scene it just bummed me out gary
oldman wasn't in the movie really at all
it could have been played by anybody it
wouldn't have affected the movie at all
and I know the natural reaction to a
statement like that's gonna be actually
Anthony Hopkins was only in Silence of
the Lambs for 15 minutes and you stole
the show that is realistically 10 more
minutes than Gary Oldman is in lawless
the thing is I don't think people are
going to get what they want out of this
movie so well yeah but some won't it's
ultimately a period piece the period
being Prohibition era Virginia but if
people want an action movie no with
tommy guns flying and they want bats
cracking over people's head well there
are a couple scenes where that those
things do happen where things like that
anyway but it's not a big part of the
movie it really is a drama it's a
realistic representation of the
Prohibition era it's like one of those
movies when a history teacher in high
school is teaching about the Prohibition
era he should probably show lawless to
the class it would do the air of justice
it's just kind of this that went
down there so I enjoyed the movie but is
this movie for everyone know if
someone's like oh dude I loved it I'll
be like oh I understand why and if
someone's like dude it poured this
out of me I'd be like yeah I understand
why ultimately lawless is a good time no
alcohol required as long as you know
what you're in for and as long as you
enjoy the Prohibition era it's
interesting but it does have its boring
I recognize that first of your
favorite Prohibition era Story movie
book show whatever make way for the
organized crime whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you
[Music]